Louis CK is creator of the show with you
CK calls you up and says Zach I want to
do this show he calls me he's like are
you interested in writing a TV show and
I said uh f u c k uh
and I thought oh I guess they need a fat
guy in this one too and I'll just be I'm
the fat guy
and I don't know why it turned to you
it's basically it's a story about uh
[Music]
Jimmy Jimmy that was a great story where
do you come up with this stuff I live in
Brooklyn and um
and I hate it
what was it like you know working on the
um
maybe the campaign the campaign shut up
I don't know were you baptized uh naked
yeah how old were you I don't remember
it was before I was 20 though I know
that yeah I was I was five well that's a
little late it was a little and it was
my first hard on
it's almost a year right uh yeah you're
old yeah is it is it a boy or a girl uh
we don't want to find out until
all week I was thinking to myself
uh don't screw this up fatty
actually a text from my mother
about the fact that I another thing I
admire many things about you but you're
really
[Laughter]
said hey uh
I hear you're on the TV sometimes why
don't you uh say something about me on
the on the TV
stop stealing my tomatoes
I have noticed that you always gain
weight for every roll
um
but then you don't lose it after
so you just you just you just keep
getting fatter
yeah
is that
is that a question no I guess not no you
spent a lot of time in Canada though
yeah uh born and raised in Edmonton and
uh
that part's not true by the way uh my
dad is Tim Horton
never forget what
my grandmother said right before
she passed away which she said to me
right before she passed away she said
what are you doing
which for baskets everywhere I mean I
see your face all the time on buses and
you know well I appreciate you saying
that
I never see your face
[Applause]
what are you talking about
[Applause]
this is very disappointing very
disappointing we're uh a lot of uh ax
body spray
but I live in a black neighborhood and
it's called ask body spray
and if you don't get that joke then
you're not racist
I was in Vegas with my mom and uh I was
at the slot machine and we were just
playing the nickel slots and uh these
three young punks came up and they were
like hey can we get our picture
um with you Zach and I went can you not
see I'm with a prostitute
people they're just so great and they're
they're so friendly and the food is just
wonderful
I totally was not listening to what you
said
I uh this movie was shot in 30 days most
movies take four months yeah this movie
is four times better than any movie I've
seen
have you ever had a situation like that
with family or whatever yeah I would
personally not qualify because I have a
lot of pre-existing uh conditions you do
yes I have a something called a cocaine
toenail
but kids crave discipline right so um
you know
prenatal spankings important
it has one
I gotta write this down prenatal
spanking two birds with one stone all
right
where you were sitting there doing uh
improv with the president of the United
States yeah at the White House yeah kind
of blew my mind I felt like we had
entered a new realm yeah for better or
ill yeah and it was it was hilarious it
was fantastic God I'd forgotten that I
interviewed the president
um
why do you keep saying congratulations
I don't know why I just uh I'm happy for
you and uh it was weird and when he
walked out it felt like I was giving you
an award or something but I don't know
why I just felt like I just haven't seen
anyone I'm happy for it thank you and
I'm proud of you congratulations on your
TV show thank you